mon cousin elvot a tenu à me montrer les
poteaux téléphoniques près de sa maison
une caméra y était fixée elle filmait
ses allées et venue mais ce savoir
contrôler n'est pas ce qui a été le pire
pour lui après les accusations la
calomnie qu'il a touché lui et sa
famille a complètement bouleversé sa vie
suite à la médiatisation de cette
histoire son employeur la licencier il a
réussi à retrouver un travail mais bien
en dessous de ses compétences ses amis
se sont détournés de lui et certains
médias l'ont décrit comme un monstre
issu forcément d'une famille monstrueuse
[Musique]
je m'appelle Laura zornita je suis
française mon père est originaire de
cette région le nord-est de l'Italie ici
zornita est un nom tristement célèbre
car c'est le nom que porte aussi mon
cousin elle vaut depuis 4 ans elle vos
ornita et soupçonnée d'être un
terroriste hors du commun plus de 30
attentats lui seraient attribués ayant
causé de nombreux blessés qui restent
parfois handicapés à vie
désigné comme un monstre il reste
pourtant en liberté et c'est lui qui
m'accueille à la porte de sa maison
il a promis de tout me raconter
[Musique]
depuis près de 15 ans les populations
des régions de Venise et de Trieste
vivent dans une inquiétude permanente
leur angoisse être victime des attentats
terroristes d'un maniaque qui frappe
sans distinction et sans jamais avoir
revendiqué l'une de ses actions ici on
l'appelle l'une à bombers italiens en
référence à Théodore kazinsky celui qui
a terrorisé les États-Unis pendant 18
ans en envoyant des colis piégés
[Musique]
officiellement la première bombe de
l'une à bombers italiens un tube
métallique a explosé le 21 août 1994 à
satile pendant la fête de la ville
o une
bombe de 30 cm de long avec à
l'intérieur de la poudre explosive et
des billes de verre
j'ai vu trois personnes les jambes
ensanglantées une femme qui s'était fait
mal et une petite fille qui criait
l'intention est de blesser pour le
moment aucune revendication n'est
parvenu au quotidien ou au télévision
dans les mois suivants une à bombers va
déposer des tubes piégés dans plusieurs
villes de la région 5 mars 1995 jour de
carnaval à
[Musique]
dans la même ville 10 minutes plus tard
nouvelle attentat
[Musique]
les attaques de Lina bombers deviennent
de plus en plus ciblées pour blesser
pour faire des victimes à coup sûr
le 4 août 1996 plage de Lignano sabiador
Roberto Curcio se rend à la mer en
famille comme tous les Italiens ils
louent un parasol afin de profiter au
mieux de cette période estivale
mais au moment d'ouvrir
la presse va suivre de près les
attentats de l'une à bombers qui
terrorisent la région car le million est
journaliste et chroniqueur judiciaires à
la nueva divinecia quotidien régional
édité à 100 000 exemplaires il est
devenu le spécialiste de cette affaire
il y a une évolution dans la
construction de ces engins
car le million est réputé pour avoir de
très bonnes sources au plus près de
l'enquête
dans les années 90 le poseur de bonbe
utilisé des tubes simples piégés
simplement
je voudrais dire qu'on apprenait à nos
militaires à construire ce genre de
bombe
qualité s'est fait vers les années 2000
quand on passe aux petits objets piégés
à l'utilisation de la nitroglycérine aux
petits circuit électrique et ça peu de
gens savent le faire
surtout manipuler la nitroglycérine
c'est un explosif je pense que peu de
personnes savent l'utiliser sans se
blesser
[Musique]
à la fin de l'année 2000 une à bomber
perfectionnée
[Musique]
il les dissimule dans des produits de
consommation courante que n'importe qui
peut acheter dans les supermarchés
italiens
faire ses courses de bien risque
d'autant plus que les produits sont
piégés il n'explose pas tout de suite
les consommateurs les achètent tout est
prévu pour qu'ils explosent chez eux
mais le climat de paranoïa est tel que
certains se méfient
en voyant un petit fil électrique sortir
d'un œuf un homme sera épargné
il repose la boîte et prévient la police
d'autres auront moins de chance il ne
détecteront pas le piège
des supermarchés ou ceux qui ont touché
des enfants avec créer une alarme une
peur monstrueuse au téléphone il ne se
passait pas un jour sans appel au
carabiniers aux policiers aux pompiers
les gens signalaient la présence d'un
objet piégé ou de quelque chose de
suspect c'était la psychose je me
souviendrai toujours que les produits du
supermarché où l'on a trouvé un objet
piégé ont tous été emmené de nuit à
l'aéroport Marco Polo et ont été
contrôlés sur le tapis roulant vous
savez où l'on voit à l'intérieur des
valises s'il n'y a pas d'objet comme un
pistolet un couteau etc
désormais chacun sait qu'il peut à tout
moment être victime de l'une à bomber
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a sauvé Pamela
Martinello
alors qu'elle tente d'ouvrir un pot de
pâte à tartiner elle entend des clics
inhabituels sans s'affoler elle dépose
le pot délicatement sur le rebord de la
fenêtre
ce geste va la sauver
et
j'ai entendu une grande déflagration qui
m'a fait halluciner car c'était très
fort
j'ai vu des fragments de verre
s'éparpillées de la maison surtout sur
le balcon parce que disons que la
déflagration est allée vers l'extérieur
par chance
la jeune femme s'est éloignée n'a pas eu
de problème il n'y a pas eu de dommages
à l'intérieur de la maison alors le
rebord de la fenêtre c'est celui-ci oui
c'est celui-là et on peut dire que la
jeune femme a eu la rapidité d'esprit de
mettre le bocal sur le rebord de la
fenêtre après quelques secondes il a
explosé
[Musique]
après les supermarchés l'une à bombers
s'attaque au lieu de culte les églises
les cimetières
fin 2001 c'est le cimetière de motard
d'illy 25 qui est visée
cette fois la bombe est dissimulée dans
un cierge
[Musique]
Anita boisis 64 ans habitué des lieux
remarque sur une tombe laissée à
l'abandon 4 bougies
quatre bougies oubliées volontairement
elle les ramasse
en 9 ans entre 1994 et 2003 une à
bombers a posé plus de 27 bombes qui ont
fait 15 victimes et sans que la police
ne puisse l'arrêter
en avril 2003 cette affaire va prendre
un nouveau tournant
le jour de la fête de la Libération sur
les rives du piavé une petite fille
française car âgée de 9 ans remarque au
pied du pont un marqueur
cet attentat est le premier qui blesse
gravement un enfant
dans le nord de l'Italie et à Venise la
population est bouleversée la police est
montré du doigt
et new Fortuna est procureur général de
la cour d'appel de Venise une enfant
nommée Francesca
près des rives du Piave et a perdu la
vue ça a peut-être été l'attentat le
plus douloureux heureusement pour nous
personne n'est mort
à partir de 2003 il va coordonner les
juridictions compétentes qui enquête sur
l'affaire
il y a bien ma boutique donc nous avons
eu pendant environ 7 ou 8 ans trop
d'intermédiaires je cite le parquet très
vite le parquet de port des nonnes le
parcelle Triest le parquet de Venise qui
sont intervenus à l'occasion de ces
différents attentats
sévit dans une localité la compétence
revient au tribunal qui se trouve là où
les faits ont été commis
il y en a eu plusieurs
c'est bien qu'au début nous avons perdu
beaucoup d'indices du fait de temps de
tribunaux de temps d'experts judiciaires
de temps de piste différentes suivis par
autant de personnes qui ont enquêté de
façon différente
à partir de 2003 à la faire une à bomber
et requalifier en affaires terroriste
tous les moyens sont mis en œuvre pour
arrêter le ou les coupables les
enquêteurs échangent leurs informations
sur les indices ils établissent des
listes de suspects certains sont
perquisitionnés et entendu par la
justice
au début il y avait tant de suspect dans
cette procuration il y avait dans la
procédure d'enquête une liste de
suspects il y en avait tellement inscrit
sur cette liste des personnes diverses
beaucoup de personnes
les enquêteurs finissent par avoir la
conviction que tous les attentats sont
le fait d'un seul homme quelqu'un qui
habite la région qui s’émanier les
explosifs qui s'est fabriqué des
détonateurs sophistiqués dans la liste
des suspects un homme à toutes ces
qualités c'est un ingénieur qui a
travaillé dans une usine d'armement un
spécialiste des mines antipersonnelles
il s'appelle et vos ornites
c'est en 2004 par ma famille que j'ai
appris qu'elle vaut avait des soucis
avec la justice qu'il commençait à être
soupçonnés dans l'affaire une à bombers
elle vaut mon cousin Luna bomber italien
je ne pouvais pas le croire aujourd'hui
il accepte de revenir sur cette chute
libre cette descente aux enfers quand
les enquêteurs ont commencé à
s'intéresser à lui
en mai 2004 ils sont arrivés chez moi il
y a eu un énorme déploiement de force
ils sont arrivés à quatre voitures ils
m'ont réveillé à 6h45 moins20
la porte dentaire
et puis ils ont dit
vous savez très bien pourquoi nous
sommes là
et franchement moi j'ai commencé à
comprendre pourquoi ils étaient là
seulement après avoir lu sur le mandat
de perquisition qu'il cherchait una
bomberquisition
pendant laquelle j'ai dû répondre à
d'interminables questions
moi le tester c'était exténuant
personne n'est préparé à subir pendant
12 heures
un interrogatoire avec des questions un
an plus finir
dans tous les sens ailleurs au moins
j'étais très très angoissée j'espère que
mon mari ne s'en est pas trop rendu
compte j'ai pensé tout de suite à ma
fille et je l'ai emporté le plus loin
possible d'ici et Michel aussi parce
qu'elle n'avait que huit ans et il me
semblait juste de la préserver avant
tout
la police ne sait pas limitée à
perquisitionner chez elvos ornita elle a
fouillé de fond en comble les
habitations de son frère et celle de ses
parents qui vivent à quelques kilomètres
de chez lui
nous étions ici ils ont sonné à la porte
tout de suite je me suis levé encore en
chemise de nuit je suis allé répondre
j'ai demandé qui c'était ils m'ont dit
c'est la police
moi je suis restée ici dans cette
position de 7 heures du matin jusqu'à
11h sans pouvoir téléphoner
ni aller dans la salle de bain
parce qu'il me l'ont interdit
[Musique]
peu de temps après la première
perquisition et vos ornita va commettre
une erreur une erreur psychologique avec
la justice
[Musique]
Roberto Ortolan et journaliste il
travaille pour le Gazzettino quotidien
tiré à 100 000 exemplaires il suit
l'affaire ornita de très près et il
s'est particulièrement intéressé à la
personnalité de l'ingénieur qu'il a
longuement interviewé à plusieurs
reprises
de par sa formation intellectuelle c'est
quelqu'un qui cherche à aider son
prochain
parce que elle vous ornita entre dans la
liste des suspects puis il devient le
super suspect
il devient le super suspect le jour où
il écrit une lettre au parquet de
Trieste qui disait je suis capable de
vous aider
que j'ai montré au préalable à mon
avocat
et une lettre exclusivement technique
dans laquelle je disais en tant que
citoyen et nous en tant que suspect je
disais ce que j'aurais fait si j'avais
été à la place des forces de l'ordre où
je vais chercher quelle piste j'aurais
suivi
vous n'avez peut-être pas assez de recul
moi de l'extérieur je peux apporter un
jugement plus serein j'ai donc transmis
mes axes de recherche
analysée par les psychologues
analysé par les enquêteurs
décisif dans le dossier contre zornita
sorte de confession
un moyen de demander de l'aide et de
dire arrêtez moi
si la bonne volonté de mon cousin ne
semble pas convaincre la police un autre
trait de sa personnalité se retourne
contre lui de nature curieuse elle vaut
possède un atelier où il aime réparer
fabriquer comprendre les choses et leur
fonctionnement
il est important de nettoyer parce que
sinon la rouille conduirait un blocage
lent irréparable de la montre elle-même
qui passe elle vote ornita est un homme
qui passe 3 à 4 heures par jour à cause
à se construire une crèche illuminée
moi je casse ma télé je la jette et j'en
achète une autre
cassée cherche une pièce de rechange et
s'il ne la trouve pas la pièce de
rechange il a construit lui-même
il y a quelques années elle vaut le
bricoleur a même essayé de faire des
feux d'artifice cette passion a poussé
les enquêteurs à chercher des preuves
dans son atelier
en avril 2006 j'ai subi encore une
perquisition
celle-ci aussi est énorme
celle-ci aussi a duré toute la journée
cette fois elle a débouché sur la
réquisition de tous mes outils
de la paire de ciseaux à la pince la
scie à la forme le couple est
pour couper les branches bref tout ce
que j'avais de tranchant m'a été pris
si le matériel de bricolage d'élevos
ornita intéresse tant les enquêteurs
c'est que toutes les bombes d'une un
bombers n'ont pas explosé et qu'elle
pourrait parler
[Musique]
30 mars 2004 église de Porto gros la
police découvre un briquet caché dans un
prix Dieu il est rempli de
nitroglycérine et comprend un détonateur
destiné à exploser lorsqu'on
s'agenouille dessus c'est cette petite
pièce de métal qui serait la pièce à
conviction contre l'ingénieur ornita
elle aurait été découpée avec l'un de
ses ciseaux entre 2004 et 2006 et vos
ornita est entendu à six reprises par
des juges d'instruction qui lui
demandent de s'expliquer de préciser ses
emplois du temps sur plus de 10 ans
pendant l'enquête le secret de
l'instruction est respecté la presse ne
s'est pas encore que l'ingénieur ornita
est devenu le suspect numéro 1
et pendant la même période une à bombeur
poursuit ses attentats comme celui du 3
mars 2005 dans l'église de motard-d'ill
evensa
[Musique]
un attentat que les forces de l'ordre
n'ont pas pu déjouer
et qui touchent au cœur l'Italie tout
entière
[Musique]
à l'époque nous avions tous en tête
l'une à bombers et ses actes terroristes
car cela faisait beaucoup d'années que
dans la région il se passait des choses
comme celle qui nous est arrivée
voire même beaucoup plus grave comme
tous parents nous étions préoccupés nous
avons prévenu nos enfants de faire
attention et de ne rien ramasser par
terre car pour tous les attentats
précédents il s'agissait d'objets au sol
mais les attentats qui ont lieu dans la
région sont imprévisibles ils sont tous
différents les uns des autres et
personne ne se serait imaginé que cela
puisse arriver par une bougie d'offrande
à l'intérieur d'une église
Greta âgé de 6 ans prend un cierge
électrique elle essaie de le faire
fonctionner en l'insérant dans le socle
prévu à cet effet
ni parvenant pas elle prend un autre
cierge et d'un adulte elle enfonce le
siège électrique dans son socle
l'explosion est terrible
méchants
avec la main déchiquetée
cela fait mal de voir une enfant de 6
ans entouré de pansement hurler pleurer
quand on la soigne
[Musique]
ce nouvel attentat ridiculise les forces
de l'ordre tout le monde se pose la même
question la police est-elle capable
d'arrêter une abombeure
pinceau je pense que c'est une personne
qui a une intelligence criminelle très
raffinée donc pour la combattre il
faudrait autant d'intelligence si ce
n'est plus
et ce n'est pas le cas
et bien disons que pour le moment les
résultats ne sont pas aussi intelligents
et raffinés que les moyens développés
par l'une à bombers
6 jours après l'attentat dont a été
victime la petite Greta une
manifestation silencieuse est organisée
à Port Danone cette célébration a lieu
tous les ans il s'agit du jour national
à la mémoire des victimes du terrorisme
à cette occasion l'Italie se souvient
des années de plomb des actions
terroristes menées par des groupes
d'extrême gauche dans les années 70 mais
en 2005 apport Denon cette journée
dédiée aux victimes du nabomber et plus
que la résignation c'est la colère qui
domine
[Musique]
ce numéro vert est mise en place pour
aider ceux qui veulent s'exprimer et
donner d'éventuelles signalement nous
avons reproduit l'expérience américaine
l'une à bombers américaine a été
capturée après 18 ans ils ne l'ont pas
découvert grâce à l'enquête mais grâce
au numéro vert c'est son frère qu'il a
livré par téléphone
de mort il y a des crimes pardonnables
et ce n'est pas de la démagogie
18 mois et trois attentats plus tard le
vœu de la population semble exaucé les
médias annoncent l'arrestation imminente
d'une bomber
la capture de Luna bombers pourrait bien
avoir eu lieu le criminel qui depuis des
années terrorise le nord-est
confectionnant des objets piégés
destinés spécialement aux enfants il
pourrait en effet avoir laissé une trace
une trace précieuse pour les enquêteurs
fin août 2006 les journalistes
apprennent qu'un ingénieur de la région
de port Denon est fortement suspecté
d'être une abombeure son nom son visage
finissent par être divulgué dans toute
la presse problème
le plus important et le plus grand choc
qui est arrivé à ma santé psychologique
puisque physique un psychiatre et
survenu à la fin de septembre 2006
pardon fin août 2006
je revenais chez moi après la messe
des chroniqueurs d'une importante
télévision nationale m'ont
interpellés
contre moi
il s'attendait à ce que je sois arrêté
d'un moment à l'autre certaines
[Musique]
pour les Italiens une à bomber a
désormais un visage l'affaire zornita
commence les indices les détails de
l'instruction sont publiés dans les
journaux
la violation du secret de l'instruction
c'est ce que n'a pas cessé de dénoncer
Paolo delagnolo l'avocat d'elvoorita
un avocat réputé dans le nord de
l'Italie pour lui l'affaire une à
bombeur illustre bien la devise qui
figure sur son ordinateur la justice
n'est pas de ce monde
jusqu'en 2006 à chaque fois que la
police l'appelait l'ingénieur ornita
allait répondre à toutes les questions
comment
et tout ça toujours dans le contexte du
secret de l'instruction
des activités de la magistrature et de
la police judiciaire la politique
dans le but de trouver le coupable il
est normal que tout soit tenu secret
je le répète ça a duré jusqu'à la fin ou
2006 quand quelqu'un une personne a
divulgué le nom et le prénom de
l'ingénieur ornita son adresse et sa vie
elle a choisi
depuis les médias les organes de presse
les télévisions et tous les autres ont
créé cette affaire mais la capitale
il m'est arrivé au supermarché de
prendre une boîte de thon puis décidé de
la reposer
une femme a regardé
elle était livide avec une expression
bien marquée sur son visage
comme une intention d'attentat
vers la caissière pour lui dire que
j'étais dans le magasin
j'ai franchement vécu une période
terrible une horrible période pendant
laquelle j'avais peur pour moi peur pour
ma fille et on peut dire que j'avais
même peur de mon ombre
elle vous ornita a été entendu à
plusieurs reprises par le juge mais il
n'a jamais été arrêté emprisonné pour la
population cette incompréhensible
puisqu'il est désigné comme l'une à
bomber par les médias paradoxe de
l'histoire c'est peut-être ce qui lui a
évité la prison
médiatique sur cet homme coupable ou
innocent elle vous ornita serait
certainement aller en prison
parce qu'en Italie des gens ont déjà été
arrêtés pour bien moins
par chance cette attention médiatique a
fait en sorte que les procureurs y sont
allés tout doucement sans action brutale
notre système offre beaucoup de
garanties tenter si bien que les gens se
plaignent car les inculpés les auteurs
des faits sont d'abord arrêtés par les
forces de l'ordre puis relâchés par les
juges et pour une journée
en réalité pour mettre quelqu'un en
prison le juge se base sur un de ces
trois éléments le délit de fuite le
risque de récidive
ou le flagrant délit
pour décider de mettre un suspect en
détention préventive le juge doit
disposer au minimum d'un de ces trois
éléments
et dans le cas de vos ornites les
procureurs parce qu'il n'en va pas de
mes attributions ont décidé que
l'épreuve en leur possession n'était pas
suffisantes
elle vous ornita n'osent plus sortir il
se taire chez lui
est l'un des rares journalistes à
prendre sa défense directeur est
présentateur de la télévision régionale
de port Denon il prône un journaliste de
combat lorsqu'il apprend que la maison
Delvaux ornita était truffée de micro il
n'hésite pas à pousser un coup de gueule
dans ma main vous voyez un microphone en
métal qui a été trouvé dans la maison du
désormais célèbre ingénieur ornita et ça
mange
ce que vous voyez est un micro
opérationnel
qui fonctionne en tout point
quand je parle avec certains politiques
de choses parfois délicates sur mon
téléphone portable chose que je fais
rarement j'en profite pour saluer le
sergent-chef celui qui m'écoute dans
notre cas je peux vraiment saluer ceux
qui m'écoutent tous ceux qui m'écoutent
oui je me suis sentie violée en somme
dans notre intimité c'est tout quand
j'ai découvert qu'il y en avait dans la
chambre là j'ai trouvé que c'était
vraiment exagéré et ensuite quand j'ai
appris qu'il y en avait aussi dans le
séjour là je lui ai dit bon allez
laisse-les nous n'avons rien à cacher de
toute façon
il était sous surveillance 24 heures sur
24 au moment où il est sous contrôle
d'autres bombes explosent alors ça veut
dire quoi
ou les enquêteurs se sont endormis
ou ce n'est pas en état
ou ornita possède un don du biscuité
car c'est peut-être le fait le plus
intrigant de cette affaire
alors qu'elle vous ornita est suspecté
sous surveillance d'autres bombes
explosent
le dernier des cinq attentats attribué à
une abonder date du 6 mai 2006 lorsqu'il
y jette une bouteille à la mer
Massimo Bosso un jeune infirmier de 28
ans ramasse cette bouteille contenant un
message qu'il ne lira jamais
alors la délai d'où elle alors de deux
choses l'une ou l'ingénieur ornita est
comme diabolique et il se travestit il
réussit à s'enfuir de nuit et de jour il
change de physique comme bien où il n'a
pas été convenablement contrôlé mais je
ne crois pas car ce devait être des
professionnels de grande qualité qui le
surveillaient ou alors il n'est pas une
à bombeur
mon cousin helvot a tenu à me montrer
les poteaux téléphoniques près de sa
maison une caméra y était fixée elle
filait ses allées et venue mais ce
savoir contrôler n'est pas ce qui a été
le pire pour lui après les accusations
la calomnie qu'il a touché lui et sa
famille a complètement bouleversé sa vie
après de brillantes études il occupait
des postes à haute responsabilités suite
à la médiatisation de cette histoire son
employeur la licencier il a réussi à
retrouver un travail mais bien en
dessous de ses compétences ses amis se
sont détournés de lui et certains médias
l'ont décrit comme un monstre issu
forcément d'une famille monstrueuse
les parents Delvaux n'arrivent toujours
pas à comprendre comment une journaliste
qui était au collège avec elle Vaud et
son frère Flavio a pu écrire de telles
horreurs particulièrement sur Flavio le
frère Delvaux qui est handicapé d'un
bras
sur l'invalie sur la validité de l'autre
suspect
Flavio sur le banquier de 52 ans ex
étudiant timide en comptabilité gestion
oui enfin ce qu'elle veut dire c'est
qu'il était un peu réservé
les versions sont contradictoires
peut-être est-il né handicapé enfant
peut être a-t-il perdu sa main à cause
d'un pétard alors qu'il jouait avec son
frère
elle Aïcha benissimo mais elle sait très
bien
comment est né mon fils
car elle était ami des camarades de
classe de Flavio
qui connaissait tous son histoire
enfant jouillon avec des explosifs ou
autre engins et pour cette raison je
n'ai pas le bras ceci est un des
exemples les plus flagrants que je
pourrais dire être
pourquoi tu n'as pas de bras
oui c'est vrai je suis né sans bras en
effet dès ma naissance tous les
documents officiels témoignent que je
suis né sans bras
mais des articles extrêmement
diffamatoires ont été écrits
certains ont dépend la personne que vous
voyez devant vous comme un monstre
on colpait d'avoir des problèmes
de pédophilie pédophilie
pour un père qui a une fille de 11 ans
comme un monstre sur lequel plane
l'ombre de la pédophilie
c'est une situation qui vraiment vous
fait réfléchir
la personne qui vous remet en cause la
personne a acheté je me suis demandé si
cela valait la peine de continuer à
vivre dans cette situation
et là je dois dire qu'un ami m'a
beaucoup aidé
mon ami oui je peux dire que c'est un
ami il m'a dit écoute quoi qu'ils disent
pense qu'un père mort c'est bien pire
qu'un criminel vivant
ce que ça excusez-moi
tu veux qu'on fasse une pause
je me suis dit que c'était un véritable
acharnement qu'il voulait trouver à tout
prix un coupable
qui est tombée dans un mécanisme un
mécanisme qui finit toujours par vous
broyer je suis de la vie d'un de mes
amis policiers qui dit
la presse est un requin et le requin si
tu ne lui donnes pas à manger c'est lui
qui va chercher à manger il y a un
requin qui a faim attention les dégâts
proche des enquêteurs Carlo million a
publié un article très documenté sur les
17 indices qui constituent le dossier à
charge contre le bows ornita de quoi
informer le public mais aussi
d'entretenir la suspicion sur elle vos
ornites
qui accuse l'ingénieur ornita ne sont
pas des preuves
la preuve réelle aurait été de trouver
l'ingénieur ornita en train de fabriquer
une bombe ou en train de la poser
les éléments trouvés sont variés le fait
que dans sa maison était trouvé les
mêmes piles qu'utilise une à bombers
les cartouches d'encre des stylos Bic
sans le tube en plastique des tubes
similaires à se retrouver sur certains
objets piégés ce sont des objets du
quotidien chez tout le monde chez moi
vous pouvez les trouver
la force du nabomber son habileté c'est
ça c'est qu'il utilise toujours des
matériaux simples que vous pouvez
retrouver dans une maison parce que
c'est ça la chose significative et
singulière nous avons beurre mais c'est
aussi la chose significative et
singulière qui désigne leur Nidor
parmi les 17 indices cités par Carlo
million il y en a un qui concerne
l'attentat du tribunal de port Denon
prie pour cible par une à bomber le 24
mars 2003
les enquêteurs auraient retrouvé la
vidéo prise par la caméra de
surveillance située dans le couloir du
tribunal
sur les images un homme ressemblerait à
elle vos ornitas
un indice de plus pour les enquêteurs
vous parlez d'indice j'ai vu un de ces
indices il y a une vidéo qui montrerait
l'ingénieur ornita entrer dans le
tribunal de port des nones
ou une bombe à explosé
pour un indice je ne sais pas s'ils
m'ont pris pour un imbécile je n'espère
pas en tout cas
je vous assure que c'est ridicule
Léa la caméra du tribunal était cassée
et surexposé
on distingue un homme peut-être que l'on
ne voit que de dos évidemment
ayant peu de cheveux ou les cheveux
blancs car ça on n'arrive pas à faire la
distinction
reste la principale pièce à conviction
la pièce de métal du détonateur du
briquet qui n'a pas explosé après 40
jours d'analyses par les plus grands
experts la police scientifique affirme
que la pièce métallique a bien été
découpée par les ciseaux saisies chez
elle vos ornita
tout est tout le monde absolument tout
le monde était convaincu que l'ingénieur
ornita était l'une à bomber que c'était
lui le coupable et nous nous avons passé
des mois à la tête basse et avec
l'ingénieur ornita qui persistait à nous
dire mais c'est pas possible cela n'est
pas possible ce n'est vraiment pas
possible
il nous a donné la force de chercher une
piste à ce moment-là nous ne pensions
pas découvrir ce que nous avons
découvert en Suisse mais nous avions une
intuition
[Musique]
mon cousin elvot a parcouru l'Italie à
la recherche d'experts pour établir une
contre expertise des experts capables
d'analyser la pièce de métal et de
déterminer avec quel outil elle a été
découpée
peu de scientifiques sont spécialistes
dans cette technique très particulière
qui consiste à analyser les empreintes
microscopiques que laissent les outils
sur le métal
[Musique]
finalement le professeur Édouard daube
un enseignant chercheur à la Faculté de
Sciences et Techniques de Rome va
relever le défi c'est lui qui a conduit
l'expertise de la voiture du champion du
monde brésilien de Formule 1 Ayrton
Senna peu après le terrible accident qui
lui a coûté la vie
le microscope qui est utilisé le
professeur belporad est capable de
produire des images en haute résolution
il n'en existe qu'un en Italie
en analysant la pièce métallique la
vérité lui saute aux yeux
il compare les photographies faites par
la police scientifique et celle faites
dans son laboratoire en les colorant
artificiellement puis en les superposant
il se rend compte qu'il manque un petit
bout de métal
la pièce a donc subi une altération le
professeur bmphorade découvre alors que
toute la pièce métallique a été façonnée
au cutter hormis une petite coupe faite
aux ciseaux
[Musique]
nous serons
certains que la coupe faite aux ciseaux
a été faite après les coupe au cutter la
grâce aux dates des photos on s'aperçoit
que cette coupe aux ciseaux a été faite
alors que la pièce métallique était à ce
moment là au laboratoire de la police
scientifique à l'achat d'or vers
ce qui nous embarrasse beaucoup c'est
que tout ça a été fait de façon
grossière
et que disons on n'aurait pas eu besoin
de tout ce déploiement de moyens pour
comprendre une chose aussi évidente et
questo et ça c'est encore plus étrange
voilà l'histoire et ça a été un moment
un moment de grande joie et aussi un
grand jour de peur car l'erreur
judiciaire était énorme
mais quand nous avons déposé au
ministère public les résultats de notre
découverte il y avait comment dire un
peu de tension
pour cette affaire de contre-expertise
la défense d'elvoorita a été renforcée
par un deuxième avocat Mauricio Panis
ténor du barreau italien et par ailleurs
député au Parlement Maurizio Panis
n'hésite pas à prendre les choses en
main
si le juge ne met bien qu'il y a eu
altération de la preuve à conviction
pour Mauricio Panis les choses vont
beaucoup plus loin
en novembre et décembre 2006 qu'en
réalité ce morceau de métal avait été
altéré manipuler
manipula
alors qu'il était en possession des
enquêteurs
à altérer la preuve en coupant lui-même
la pièce de métal avec la paire de
ciseaux
il y a l'audience la rencontre
probatoire concernant l'altération de la
pièce métallique à altération tous les
journalistes sont là à la sortie du
tribunal la télé tout ça
et son avocat panique
il y a ici la preuve manipulation
l'expertise parle clairement il y a eu
manipulation cette preuve n'a plus
aucune valeur il le dit comme ça le
lendemain les journaux titres
manipulation la preuve n'existe plus la
preuve est en faveur de zornites mais
les conclusions de l'expert ne sont pas
celles-ci
pour les avocats de vos ornita c'est une
manipulation volontaire d'après la
conclusion du parquet la seule pièce à
conviction qui est incriminé elle vos
ornita a été altérée la justice cherche
donc à en savoir plus ce qui est certain
c'est que la paire de ciseaux et la
pièce métallique étaient en possession
du laboratoire de la police scientifique
lorsque la pièce a été coupée
[Musique]
ce laboratoire est dirigé par eziozernar
une référence de la police scientifique
mais désormais c'est sur lui que les
regards se braquent
il est dans le collimateur de la justice
pour falsification de preuves
les médias suivent de presse scandale
qui révèlent les dysfonctionnements de
la justice italienne suspecté d'avoir
manipulé la pièce métallique retrouvée
dans un objet piégé qui n'a pas explosé
dans l'affaire Yuna bomber Bernard ira
en procès le 28 novembre prochain devant
le tribunal de Mestre Bernard a renoncé
à l'audience préliminaire il a demandé
directement un procès
il est certain que c'est lui qui a
demandé l'analyse sur la pièce de métal
Ikea
donc aujourd'hui je peux dire qu'il est
l'accusé de ses faits
pour plusieurs raisons
il voulait à tout prix trouver un
coupable
c'était devenu un point d'honneur pour
les enquêteurs de réussir à identifier
un responsable
ils avaient travaillé beaucoup d'années
sans obtenir de résultats
et il y allait de leur fierté
personnelle
il faut dire que celui qui dirigeait ce
laboratoire
jouit d'une certaine liberté
comme le droit de pouvoir se déplacer
d'agir librement sans compte à rendre
c'était un privilégié à tout point de
vue
le directeur de la police scientifique
avec un procès à venir toujours aucune
piste sérieuse dans l'enquête sur elle
vous ornites des sommes faramineuses
dépensées pour le parquet de Venise le
fiasco judiciaire est total
nous n'avons pas eu de chance nous avons
découvert avec effroi que ça n'est pas
l'ingénieur suspecté de la paternité des
attentats qui a coupé la pièce
métallique avec ses ciseaux
père de ciseaux qui était une preuve
décisive d'après l'empreinte laissée par
le ciseau sur l'objet coupé mais cette
coupe a été faite par le policier qui
détenait ses fameux ciseaux
c'était une chose absolument
imprévisible absolument je dirais
désastreuse pour nous
disas
nous devons enquêter sur celui qui est
censé enquêter sur l'affaire on abomar
notre policier de Venise c'est ce
policier qui aurait d'après l'accusation
fabriqué ce faux effectivement comme
c'est un de nos collaborateurs ça a été
très douloureux pour nous aussi parce
que c'était une personne extrêmement
estimée des experts et donc ça a été
comme trouver un traître parmi nous et
donc ça a été très très douloureux
mais comment expliquer ça pour quel
motif leur est-il altéré
je crois que la raison est facile à
expliquer si vous avez déjà vu quelques
films américains il a essayé d'obtenir
la gloire en trouvant la preuve contre
l'auteur de ses attentats
plus de 30 attentats une quinzaine de
victimes l'une des plus grosses affaires
criminelles d'Italie et aussi une preuve
apparemment fabriquée par la police
contre mon cousin je pense à elle vaut
et sa famille au mal qu'ils ont subi à
tout se gâchis quand une société a peur
quand elle s'affole il faut des
coupables des boucs émissaires ça
rassure tout le monde ça fait vendre des
journaux et tant pis si des innocents
nous espérons que cela se termine
avant de mourir nous espérons que tout
cela soit fini
c'est ça
nous souhaitons que cette histoire se
termine
il serait temps de recommencer à vivre
chez nous
et je pense que cette histoire nous a
encore plus soudée c'est sûr que ma vie
n'a pas été facile j'ai eu des
expériences négatives mais celle-ci m'a
renforcé disons
elle m'a permis aussi de connaître
encore mieux la personne avec qui je
suis et maintenant je peux dire que nous
resterons ensemble pour toujours
le problème est le suivant
réussir à résister parce que je le
répète parfois l'homme est très fort
mais d'autres fois il subit les lois de
la nature et n'a pas sa résistance
donc il se demande si ça vaut la peine
de vivre de cette façon
[Musique]
est-ce que ça vaut la peine que toutes
ces accusations te soient faites
t'écrase comme une centrifugeuse est une
peu rien faire pour t'en sortir et
ensuite personne ne te dira jamais tu as
été courageux tu as fait de ton mieux
regarde tu n'y étais pour rien
parce que la réponse finale est vraiment
celle-ci quel que soit l'issue de cette
affaire personne ne me dira jamais que
je n'avais rien à voir avec tout ça
[Musique]
malgré l'absence de preuve pour elle
vous ornita cette histoire n'est pas
terminée
si le parquet de Venise à Claude le
dossier la procédure est toujours en
cours auprès du parquet de Triest la
deuxième juridiction en charge de la
faire une abombeure
elle vous ornita est donc toujours
considéré comme le principal suspect de
cette affaire
mais aucun procès n'est prévu pour le
moment
[Musique]
il a subi d'énormes préjudices et j'en
suis vraiment navré pour lui mais nous
avons fait ce que nous avions à faire la
procuration de Venise pas moins en
particulier mais la procuration de
Venise avec ses substituts la
procuration de Trieste et ses substituts
tous les officiers judiciaires qui ont
été sur cette complexe à faire on fait
le maximum
j'en suis désolé si en état est innocent
j'en suis désolé vraiment
dans les prochains mois avec le procès
du chef de la police scientifique
viendra peut-être le temps des excuses
des réparations mais ce procès sera
aussi l'occasion de remettre en cause un
système judiciaire italien souvent
critiqué
par détruire des personnes
est broyée qu'elle s'est ruinée pour se
défendre
au final cette personne est complètement
détruite
par exemple si je t'accuse je n'ai pas
approuver mes accusations j'ai tout mais
c'est à toi de me démontrer que mes
accusations sont fausses ce genre de
choses existe dans les pays
sous-développés ou pire
et bien dans ce domaine il faut croire
que l'Italie fait partie de ces pays
sous-développés
[Musique]
depuis deux ans aucune bombe n'a explosé
une à bomber court toujours
mais il a peut-être fait une dernière
victime
le système judiciaire italien
[Musique]